The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOB FIELD: I'm Bob Field.
This is my 44th year
at MIT, and I've
taught this course
roughly half the time,
so it is my favorite course.
And I'm a
spectroscopist, and that
means that I use
quantum mechanics
almost like breathing.
And I'm going to try to convey
some of the beauty and utility
of quantum mechanics.
This is not a typical
undergraduate quantum mechanics
class.
It's not about history.
It's not about philosophy.
It's about use-- use
for understanding
complicated stuff,
use for insight.
And so a lot of
the material is not
in the assigned text,
which is a very good book,
but it's mostly a safety net.
The printed notes, all of which
are posted except for a few
lectures that I'm
still working on--
and that is the text.
Everything in the notes,
you're responsible for.
There are sections of the
notes which I call non-lecture.
That's explanation of what's
in the lecture or a little bit
going beyond it.
You're responsible for that.
If I don't finish all the
material in the notes,
you're responsible for the
material I didn't finish.
You can ask me
questions about it.
You can ask your TAs
But there's a
supplementary text,
which is a book
that I wrote which
is intended to take
undergraduates like you
to the frontier of
research in spectroscopy.
This is the book that I used to
use to teach graduate quantum
mechanics.
So I've written a lot of
stuff which is already
available on the
web, but I just want
to make sure that you know
the structure of the course.
There are going to be nine
problem sets, always in weeks
there is not an exam--
when there is not an exam.
And the problem sets
are worth 100 points.
There will be three
50-minute exams, to which you
will be allotted 90 minutes.
And they'll be evening exams
and on Thursday nights.
OK, there will be a final
during final exam period.
And so the points for
the course add up to 600.
For each exam, you will be
entitled to bring one 8 1/2
by 11 page that you've prepared
with as dense or as coarse
writing as you want--
a different one page, only
one page, for each exam
and for the final.
One page-- the exam--
one page for the exam.
One page for the final.
Not four pages
for the final, not
two pages for the
second exam, et cetera--
one page.
I believe that writing these
pages of notes or pages
of things you should
remember provide structure
that you actually learn
by preparing this,
and so I stick to this.
My job here is to
force you to suspend
what you expect about the
way matter and light behave.
You expect things based
on your experience
with macroscopic objects,
and you're very smart.
You're here at MIT
because you are
able to integrate
those expectations
and to express them in
mathematical analysis
of your observations.
So you're pretty good at that.
But quantum mechanics
forces you to step away
from what you think you
understand perfectly
because it doesn't apply
in microscopic systems.
And so I'm going to destroy your
expectations about how things
work at the beginning,
and by the end,
I will give them back
to you in the form
of things called wave packets.
Wave packets are quantum
mechanical particle-like
objects.
They obey the rules, and they do
a lot of the things you expect.
But initially, you
have to suspend
that belief in particles.
OK, so I'm going to start by
throwing a piece of chalk.
I have to throw it at my TAs.
So here is a piece of
chalk, and the chalk
followed a trajectory.
If you're a major
league outfielder,
you look at the initial
part of a trajectory,
and you can pretty much figure
out where you have to go.
This sort of thing would
be the subject of 801,
but the outfielders
don't know physics.
They just have
instincts, and they
know that if they look at the
beginning of a trajectory,
they can predict where it
will end and when it will end,
and this is really important.
That's the macroscopic view.
We talk about trajectories.
In quantum mechanics,
there are no trajectories.
We have possibly an
observation of what
was the initial condition and
what was the detection event,
but we can't describe
what's going on
by observing, point by point,
the position and momentum.
We're only allowed to do what
we call click-click experiments.
We start something in some
kind of a well-prepared state,
and then we detect what
has happened at the end.
We might do something to
the system in between,
but we cannot observe everything
as the system evolves.
And here, I will
attempt to a little bit
justify that you need to
suspend what you believe.
I threw a piece of chalk.
It could have been a baseball.
And suppose now I
said, let's decrease
the mass of the thrower, the
catcher, and the object by 100.
You pretty much know
exactly what will happen.
Now let's decrease
it by a factor of 10
to the 20, which is like going
from a baseball to an electron.
You think you might know, but
I guarantee you don't know.
And you're going
to be surprised,
and it's because in
the microscopic world,
observation modifies
the state of the system,
and any sort of interaction
of the evolving system
is going to affect
what you observe.
And so we have to create a
formal structure, which is
a kind of measurement theory.
What measurements are
we allowed to make,
and what do they tell us?
Because you cannot observe
the time dependence.
You can calculate what the
time dependence is if you know
enough, but you cannot observe
the thing evolving except
by destroying it.
OK, so quantum
mechanics is beautiful
because it describes
the microscopic world,
and it doesn't tell
you you're wrong
about the macroscopic world.
It matches everything the
macroscopic world does.
OK, some of the key ideas
of quantum mechanics--
so you do a series of
identical experiments.
You don't get the same
result. It's probabilistic,
and that should bother
you because if you
do an experiment
carefully, you're
trained to think that
you do it carefully,
you'll get the same result.
But quantum mechanics says,
tough luck.
You can't do an
experiment that carefully.
There's also this
wave-particle duality.
You know what particles
are and what the properties
of particles are.
You learn that in 8.01.
You know what waves are, and
you probably also learned
that in 8.01 or 8.02.
But you know instinctively
that particles and waves
behave differently.
But in quantum
mechanics, everything
is both particle-like
and wave-like,
and this is also something
that should bother you.
And the third thing is
energy quantization.
Now, I said I'm
a spectroscopist,
so I live and die by
these spectra, which
consist of transitions
between energy levels.
And these transitions
between energy levels
encode everything
we want to know
about the mechanics
of an object--
its structure, what it does.
And so quantum mechanics
is an elaborate encoder
of information, and
it's usually encoded
in the form of these
quantized energy levels.
And so you're
going to want to be
able to calculate how the energy
levels or the spectrum that you
would observe for an object
is related to the thing that
describes what it can do.
And that's the Hamiltonian,
and the Hamiltonian we'll
look at in many useful ways.
Now, I just want to
warn you that there
are two ways of
presenting quantum
mechanics-- the Schrodinger
picture, which is differential
equations and wave
functions, and the Heisenberg
picture, which is
matrix mechanics, where
we have matrices and
we have eigenvectors.
And I am an advocate.
I'm passionate about the matrix
picture because what it does
is presents everything in
a way that you can then
organize your insights, whereas
the Schrodinger picture mostly
involves solving one
complicated differential
equation after another, and the
focus is on the mathematics,
and it's much harder
to see the big picture.
Now, that means you need to know
a little bit of linear algebra.
Now, most of you haven't taken
a course in linear algebra,
but that doesn't matter because
the amount of linear algebra
you need to know for quantum
mechanics is extremely small,
and I will probably present
all of it in lectures.
But you will definitely
have the TAs as a resource,
and it's possible that they
will give some formal lectures
on linear algebra
or some handouts,
but it's not complicated.
It's beautiful.
OK, so light.
Light is electromagnetic
radiation.
You've heard that.
And it is both wave-like
and particle-like.
Now, the particle-like aspect
of light is going to bother you,
but it's very easy to
show that it's necessary.
OK, so first of all, what are
some wave characteristics?
If you have a wave, what
kind of measurements
are you going to make on it?
OK, Sasha.
AUDIENCE: Intensity
at a point in space.
BOB FIELD: There can be
intensity at a point in space,
but there could also be
particles that are impinging
on that point, so you need
something a little bit more
that is definitely
wave-like, and you have--
yes?
AUDIENCE: It has a frequency and
a wavelength and an amplitude.
BOB FIELD: Yes.
I'm angling for
something more, but it
does have a frequency
and a wavelength,
and wavelengths are
how you understand
interference effects.
And when you put light through
a lens, there's refraction.
When you put light
on a grating, there's
diffraction-- or
through a pinhole.
And there's the
two-slit experiment,
where you send light on an
object which has two slits,
and you can't tell which
slit the light went through.
This is a very beautiful
thing which I will talk about
in a coming lecture--
in fact, lecture number three.
So the key properties of waves
are refraction, diffraction,
two-slit experiment.
And behind that is
interference effects.
So we can have just a comic
book picture or a cartoon.
So here is a wave, and
here is another wave.
And this other wave has exactly
the same frequency and phase.
And if we add these
two guys together,
we get something
that looks like that.
And in fact, the addition
is a little bit nonlinear.
So we have constructive
interference,
or we can have destructive
interference and anything
in between.
If we add these two guys,
what you get is nothing.
So here, you get an intensified
wave-- constructive.
And here, we get cancellation.
Now, it's a little
bit stressful to think
that if particles have
wave characteristics,
they can annihilate
each other, so you'll
have to be prepared for that.
So quantum mechanics exploits
constructive and destructive
interference.
That's at the core, and you
have to get used to that,
and you have to get used to
seeing particles do that.
OK, so waves have a
frequency and a velocity
and a wavelength.
And now here, what is nu?
Nu is c over lambda.
If someone on the
telephone or on Skype
constantly asks
you "what is new,"
you can put an end
to that behavior
by saying c over lambda.
And if you do it often
enough, it'll stop.
It may be that the
question will be rephrased,
but it's useful to remember
this as a repellent and also
as a crucial
organizing principle.
OK, waves are
electromagnetic, and so that
means we have transverse
electromagnetic waves.
And so here is one
part of the wave,
and here is another
part of the wave.
And this is the electric
And so we have zero,
and here is E0.
And this is the magnetic part
of the wave, zero and B0.
And this is in the xz plane.
This is the z direction.
And this is the yz plane.
Now, this corresponds to
a wave which is linearly
polarized along the x-axis.
And so this is-- it's kind
of hard to draw a transverse
electromagnetic wave, but
there's an electric part
and a magnetic part.
And for the most part,
I forget about this.
The magnetic resonance-- this is
the only thing you care about,
but they're both part of light.
And OK.
So we have these waves, and
now, the intensity of the light
is proportional to
the E0 squared--
the electric field squared.
And it's also measured in
watts per square centimeter.
And this is in--
so this is in volts
per centimeter squared.
Now, I'm an old fashioned guy.
I use centimeters
instead of meters.
You'll just have to forgive me
for that, not using MKS units.
But the important thing
is that the intensity
is related to the square
of an electric field.
So suppose we have light
impinging on a hunk of metal.
So a metal is something
where the electrons are
free to move around, and so we
like a metal because of that.
We could ask, well, what
happens if we put light
on salt or on some
organic molecule?
And in some sense, there is
going to be a relationship,
but the easy thing is if we put
a beam of light onto a metal
and it's pushing the
electrons around.
That's what an
electric field does.
It moves the electrons.
And so you would
expect classically
that at high enough
intensity, you're
going to start ripping
electrons out of the metal,
and that would be wrong.
And this is the
photoelectric effect.
This is what we observe.
0-- the current divided by
the charge of the electron.
So that's the number of
electrons per second,
and this is the intensity.
And if we have
infrared radiation,
nothing happens, no
matter how strong it is.
If we have
ultraviolet radiation,
we have something happening.
As the intensity of
the light increases,
the number of electrons per
second ejected from the metal
increases linearly.
So why is that?
We expect that it would be
intensity that determines it,
but it's the color of the
light that determines.
We can also do something
like this, where we again
ask, what is the current divided
by the charge of the electron
versus frequency?
And again, we have 0 here.
And what we see is nothing
up until some critical point,
and then this is--
so this is some special
frequency, which
is different for every metal.
And then, all of a sudden,
we start getting electrons.
And this increases linearly,
or at least for a while
increases linearly
with the frequency.
So there's something about
the frequency of light
that rips out the electrons.
It has to be above
a certain minimum,
and then the electrons
increase with the frequency,
but in a little bit more
complicated way than linearly.
And so I have something in the
notes which is not quite right,
but this onset is important.
So these observations
suggest that the electron
is bound to the metal by some
energy which we call the work
function, and it's called phi.
And so this is the energy that
it takes to rip an electron out
of a metal.
And so it's called
the work function,
and work functions
for metals range
from a little over
1 electron volt
to around 5 electron volts.
I'm going to use those units.
Well, you can forget that.
But all metals are within
a relatively narrow range
of work functions, and this
is somehow related to nu 0.
So this is an energy,
and this is a frequency.
And so we expect that there is
some relationship between nu
0 and this energy, and there is
some proportionality concept,
which I can call
anything I want,
but I'm going to call
it h because it's going
to become Planck's constant.
That's the
proportionality concept.
And so the onset of
ejection of electrons
is when the
frequency of light is
greater than the work function.
As I said, every metal has
a different work function.
OK, so this is
looking like somehow,
the light does not act in an
additive way on the metal.
It acts in a
singular way somehow.
There are particles of light
that have definite energy.
This is what it
looks like, and we're
going to call those
particles of light photons.
And so now we're
trying to think of,
all right, electromagnetic
radiation comes as particles.
What are the properties
of particles?
Well, particles-- well, I'm
getting ahead of myself,
but as long as I
said this, particles
have kinetic energy
and momentum.
Kinetic energy is
a scalar quantity.
Momentum is a vector quantity.
And right now,
what we want to do
is measure the kinetic energy of
the electrons that are produced
by the annihilation of photons.
OK, and so we can imagine
an apparatus like this.
Here is our metal, and
here is the light impinging
on the metal.
And we have grids.
We have a ground, and we have
another grid and a detector.
So we have ground voltage is 0.
Here we have a
voltage less than 0.
Electrons don't like that.
But these two grids are
at the same potential.
So the electrons don't
know which way to go.
And then there's another
grid where we have
the potential is V plus V stop.
And so what happens is if the
electron is ejected with enough
kinetic energy to
go uphill and cross
through this potential,
this grid, then
it will make it to the
detector and we'll count it.
So this is just a
crude apparatus.
If you were going to
do this experiment,
you would probably
design it better.
But the idea is
what we want to do
is to measure what is
the voltage that we
apply that causes the electrons
to stop reaching the detector.
And that's the way we
measure the kinetic energy
of the electrons.
When all of the electrons
stop hitting the detector,
we know the voltage,
the stopping voltage.
And we can now plot
V stop.
Versus frequency.
And here is nu 0.
And what we see is this.
We see that below nu 0, there
are no electrons ejected.
Once we're above nu 0,
electrons start being ejected.
And they have a kinetic energy,
which is measured by V stop.
And it increases
linearly with frequency.
Now, when we do this
experiment on different metals,
the slope is constant, the same.
It's universal.
So the kinetic energy
of the ejected electrons
is equal to some constant.
It goes as minus nu 0.
And this is the same
constant that we saw before.
And this is Planck's constant.
And now what we've seen is
that these particles of light
have definite energy.
They have definite
kinetic energy.
And we can stop and they
transfer that energy.
And so we can draw an
energy level diagram.
So here's 0 and here.
So this is energy.
And this is minus
the work function.
And so we have a photon,
which has this energy.
And we have the kinetic
energy of the electrons.
And this is h nu minus h nu 0.
OK.
This story is complete.
The photoelectron effect
is the easiest thing
to understand at the beginning
of quantum mechanics.
And it says that light
comes in particles,
which we call photons.
And the energy of
a photon is h nu.
h is a fundamental constant.
And we know what nu is.
OK.
I'm going to talk about
Compton scattering.
But Compton scattering
is a little bit harder
to understand than the
photoelectron effect.
And I'm going to put
equations on the board which
I'm not going to derive.
They're easily derived.
But this is just to
complete the picture
of the particle-like
characteristic of Planck.
So for Compton scattering,
we have a beam of x-rays.
X-ray is a form of light.
It's a very high
energy form of light.
We have a block of paraffin.
And what we observe is there
are electrons kicked out.
And there is x-ray scattered.
So the experiment is we're
looking for the particle
characteristics.
Particles have kinetic energy
and they have vector momentum.
And you have been trained
painfully and completely
in conservation of
energy and momentum,
because it enables you to solve
all sorts of useful problems.
So suppose the x-ray
comes in, hits the block.
And so we have the
incident momentum
and the x-ray is backscattered.
And the scattering angle
theta is measured this way.
So the difference in
momentum for this scattering
is large for backscattering
and much less for forward
scattering.
Now, this momentum has to be
transferred to the electron.
And so we can draw
conservation diagrams.
Or for this case,
the backscattering.
We have pn.
We have the
electron, p electron.
And we have the
momentum of the x-ray.
OK, so this diagram
determines the momentum
transferred to the electron.
And if the x-ray photon
transfers energy to the--
it transfers momentum
to the electron,
it also transfers energy.
So what we're going
to see-- and I'm just
going to wave my hands, because
the mathematical analysis
is something you can do, but
I don't want to go through it.
I just want to show the
structure of the argument.
What you measure
is the wavelength
of the x-ray out minus the
wavelength of the x-ray in.
And so if the x-ray
has transferred energy
to the electron, it has
less energy when it leaves,
and it has longer wavelength.
So this is measurable, the
change in the wavelength
of the x-ray, and
that's going to be--
so we'll call that delta lambda.
And that's going to be a
function of the scattering
angle.
So Compton scattering basically
says, OK, light is a particle.
Particles have kinetic
energy and momentum.
Conservation of
energy and momentum
predicts a difference, a
redshift of the photon,
which depends on the
scattering angle.
The rest is all 8.01.
You can do that.
OK.
And so what you end up finding
is that if the scattering is 0,
then delta lambda is 0.
There is no momentum.
The photon just goes through.
If the scattering is
pi, in other words,
it's perfectly
backscattered, then
delta lambda you
can calculate is
2h over the mass of the electron
times the speed of light.
Now, this quantity,
h over the mass
of the electron times
the speed of light,
has dimensions of length.
And it's 0.02 or 3 angstroms.
And this is called the Compton
wavelength of the electron.
Because the photon is
scattering an electron.
The change in wavelength of the
photon is determined by this.
This is the momentum transfer.
This gives you the
momentum transferred.
And so this is a
universal constant.
It says electrons
have, when they're
scattered out of any
material, have this behavior.
Again, universal and strange.
The actual experiment,
since what you actually
want to measure is the
change in lambda over lambda.
The change in lambda doesn't
depend on lambda but this does.
And so what you
want to do is make
the observable thing large.
And so you go to
a short wavelength
to make this a large fractional
change that's easily measured.
OK.
The equations are derived
in the lecture notes
and better in texts.
And what I want to do
now is just tell you
where we're going.
We've talked about the wave
and particle nature of photons,
of light.
And the particle
nature is a surprise,
but it's perfectly
understandable and observable.
The next thing we want
to do is determine
the wave nature of things
that we call particles.
And so we're going to do other
kinds of simple scattering
experiments where we discover
that the electron-- so we
have some solid.
And we have UV light or x-rays.
And we go through this solid.
And it's mostly transparent.
It's mostly free space.
And so this light is
interacting with the electrons.
And maybe with the
other stuff that
is involved in
matter, the nuclei.
But the important thing
is that the electrons
that get scattered are in
a kind of a diffuse state.
This is mostly nothing.
This material doesn't
scatter x-rays.
It's mostly transparent.
And so an explanation for that
is the Rutherford planetary
model, where we have a
nucleus with a charge
and electrons
orbiting that nucleus.
And that's all very nice.
It's a way of saying,
well, OK, the electrons
are forced to choose
distances from the nucleus.
And there's mostly empty space.
But then you look more
closely, and the electrons
are doing this.
They're oscillating
in space, and they're
going to radiate energy.
And this radiation
of energy will
cause the electrons to
spiral in and combine
with the charge in the middle.
And that's a problem.
And so we have an explanation
for why matter is mostly
empty space and a conundrum.
The electron should
recombine with the nucleus.
So how can matter be
relatively non-compressible?
And the best explanation
is this planetary idea.
But then we have this
thing we have to explain.
Now, there's two
hypotheses for this, which
are really just ad hoc things.
One is the Bohr model where it
says, in order for the electron
to obey some laws of physics
as it orbits the nucleus,
it conserves angular momentum.
Well, if it were rotating
combined with the nucleus,
it wouldn't do that.
And so that's sort of OK.
And then there's de Broglie,
who was a very smart person.
And he said that in
order for the electron
not to annihilate itself as
it goes around the orbit,
it has to have an integer
number of half wavelengths
along that trajectory.
Then it won't annihilate itself.
And that is much better
than Bohr's hypothesis.
But both of these
hypotheses lead
to line spectra
hydrogen where you
can build a really simple
model and you can predict
to eight decimal places
all the absorption
transitions of hydrogen atom.
So a very simple model
leads to an incredibly
powerful and mysterious result.
There is another experiment that
I will talk about next lecture.
And that is suppose we
have a thin sheet of metal.
We have photons,
x-rays, or UV photons,
impinging on this metal.
There's diffraction
because there
is regular distances
between the atoms
in the particle in the foil.
And so what we measure
is diffraction rings
for the electron
and for the photon.
And the diffraction
rings are identical when
you choose the wavelength
of the particle
to be equal to the
wavelength of the photon.
And so this is another way of
showing wave particle duality.
We can show that
they have wavelengths
and we can calculate
to make them the same.
So this is all very exciting.
And this is about as much
philosophy and history
as you're going to get from me.
Once we understand that there
is something that we have to do,
which is called
quantum mechanics,
we're going to start
solving problems and then
being able to understand
incredibly complicated effects
beyond the simple problems.
And that should be exciting, but
it should also be a little bit
disturbing, because I will use
a technique called perturbation
theory, which for some
reason all of the textbooks
for a course at this level
either ignore or treat
in the most superficial way.
But perturbation theory is
a way of taking problems
that we understand
and can solve exactly.
And exactly means an infinite
number of states, all of which
are given to us by
solving one equation.
And we can then use them
to understand problems
we can't solve exactly.
And there'll be several ways
in which I deal with that.
OK, so it's time to stop.
And I hope you're excited about
what lies ahead, because it
is strange and wonderful.
And it says we can
look inside a molecule.
We can make measurements.
We can understand what this
molecule is going to do.
But we have to develop
our new way of doing that.
OK, thank you.